it's
incredible you
live you die this the in between it
counts I got a proposition for you need
you to take my boat out for a run yeah
okay
pop to I was wondering maybe you need an
extra deck hand my brother I'm curious
curious about what Charlie about me
about you two me
we're going to show you what real
fishermen can do we go some Canadian
Waters what happens if we get caught I
got a
new getting caught is not an
option Canadian Coast
Guard your vessel's been
seized if I got a $100,000 fine I'm
going to lose my father's boat now that
the day is over I never should have
trusted you I do not understand the way
you're built you built
[Music]
me I can't help you you're going to have
to do just what I ask you
to I like my resources you want to do
business well Maybel here said you guys
are one time and but if this works out
this is it one time
[Music]
only do you know what line you're
crossing right now
I she set us
[Music]
up
you you
[Music]
die it's the in between that
counts what can you do and it's get
over